[Music]
[Applause]
uh ross tucker played for bill belichick
i don't did you ever talk to bill
belichick while you played in new
england ross
yeah three times
okay
how long were those three conversations
uh actually you know what four times um
the first three
were probably three to five words i
would say
uh the last time we actually had a sit
down was when he traded me to cleveland
that was the only time i actually had a
conversation with him no and they signed
me midway dan through the 05 season
he and i just went in the team meeting
room
and it was the first meeting and he
walked up the steps to meet me
and i stand up to shake his hand he says
you don't just stand up
that was it
and then uh about a week later in
practice i fell on the ground and and he
had this really interesting way and
ability
to talk to you without anybody else
knowing he was talking to you as he was
walking by you so i fell in practice all
of a sudden like behind my right ear i
heard somebody say
stay off the freaking ground
and then uh
and then when we played jacksonville in
the playoffs jacksonville starting
center was actually
my teammate at princeton
and he said like over my left shoulder
walking away we got half the princeton
offensive line in this game
those are the only three things he said
to me dan until i got traded to
cleveland i promise you
did he know your name
yeah i mean he didn't ever use it but i
think he was generally aware of it yes
all right uh full introduction ross will
be on the call tonight the eagles at the
jet 7 30 eastern on the eagles
television network
a couple of things here that we'll get
to um who do you think has a better
chance get get back to the super bowl
chiefs of the buccaneers
i'll say bucks and i'll say the bucks
for two reasons number one
i think the nfc is easier you know you
look at the afc
i think buffalo's legit cleveland's
legit baltimore has a shot even maybe
pittsburgh has an outside shot
you look at the nfc
dan how many teams in the nfc do we
really think
can beat tom brady and this buccaneers
team in the playoffs
i think green bay maybe uh
i guess
one of the nfc west teams if russell
wilson or matthew stafford goes crazy
but i don't see it happening so
the combination of the nfc being easier
and the chiefs essentially having
three rookie offensive linemen starting
at center right guard and right tackle
i'll lean with the bucks
handicapped the nfc east for me
washington ended up winning that
division
but
you're looking at a division that might
be the worst division in football
i think it's pretty jumbled again man i
really do i think
all four teams probably win between
seven and ten games maybe six in ten
games i happen to think and people will
say i'm biased but i think the eagles
are gonna be better than
outside opinions seem to think they have
a top five offensive line and defensive
line if those guys stay healthy and
carson wentz unfortunately
led the nfl in interceptions and sacks
last year and didn't play the last four
games i mean think about basketball or
baseball he's other sports stand you
lead the league in two categories and
you don't play 25 percent of the season
if hertz just throws
five less interceptions and takes five
less sacks there's a couple wins right
there the team i don't have a great
handle on is the giants i think
washington is the favorite i know
everybody says dallas to me dallas still
has issues on defense and
there's a lot of injury concerns there
dak and amari cooper the offensive line
still
i think washington they won the division
last year the defense is beastly i like
some of their additions and i think
they're going to get much better
quarterback play than ryan fitzpatrick
than they got from alex smith and dwayne
haskins last year yeah the defense is
going to be elite it'll be right there
with the rams is the best defense in
football my concerns are the skill
position players for washington and with
ryan fitzpatrick because he's a great
story but he giveth and he taketh away
um
i i just
they don't have a great tight end they
don't have a great number one wide
receiver they don't have a that marquee
running back
but you know can you win with defense in
the nfl i guess that's what it comes
down to because the rams realized hey we
can have a great defense we still need
to have offense let's go out and get
matthew stafford
yeah well so so for the washington skill
guys i think they're all probably a
little bit better
than you give them credit for terry
mclaurin logan thomas antonio gibson and
your point about fitz is well taken dan
every fourth game or so he has a bad
game right but they don't need to go
14-3 or 13-4 they probably only need to
win 10 or 11 games so he can have a fit
stinker you know every fourth or fifth
game as long as the other three or four
he plays well so there's fitz magic and
fitz stinker
i just made that up and i'm actually
really good friends with him and i'm
probably going to hear about this later
i don't know where that came from and i
apologize to everyone did you face him
in college
no he was uh i think he was a freshman
when i was a senior
and uh it's a shame that evidently he
wasn't able to get accepted to princeton
and go to the number one school in the
country
if i said you could never tell anybody
you went to princeton and never wear any
kind of gear that said you went to
princeton would you have gone to
princeton
yes yeah for sure okay you know why well
first of all i don't need to say i went
to princeton because it seems like
everybody already knows
the gear thing is an issue though dan
because
every time i go back they give me a
bunch of stuff so i have like all my dry
fit stuff
is princeton which is hilarious because
when i drop my daughters off at their
private school everybody looks at me as
like i think i'm great or some academic
snob they have no idea meanwhile um
meathead james van der beek they think i
like think i'm some academian but by the
way they all care way more about
academics than i do
meathead james van der beek
yeah you see my shirt dan let's see
no such thing as boneless wings that's
one of ours that's that's an old school
shirt that's right i don't know if it's
still available on the website but it's
one of my favorites because
you wear this anywhere especially if you
wear this around fancy people it sets a
tone right away about where the
conversation is going to be for the rest
of that day
he's ross tucker former nfl offensive
lineman host of the ross tucker football
podcast
eagles preseason color analyst
are you pro
cleveland browns
yes very much so very much so their
roster
is so good it's kind of unbelievable
isn't it that
what was it like two years ago or three
years ago they won one game and now
i'm not sure there's a better roster in
the nfl top to bottom i mean it's right
there with buffalo and tampa
and kansas city really the difference
between the browns and those other three
teams
is whether or not baker mayfield can
play at that high of a level you know
the way josh allen played last year
mahomes of course brady of course but
other than that i mean they get odell
beckham jr back they've got two good
tight ends the best offensive line in
football two good running backs now
they've got a really good defensive line
that they invested in i love the guys
they got in the secondary like john
johnson
from the ram it's kind of weird to be on
your show talking about the browns
having maybe the best roster in football
but it really it's a beautiful roster
they've done an awesome job
do they have a great quarterback or a
good quarterback
i think so far they have a good
quarterback i think
kevin stefanski did an unbelievable job
with them last year and let's be honest
dan
if you're playing behind the best o line
in the league
and you have the best running back duo
and you're averaging whatever it is over
five yards of carry
and most of what you're doing in the
passing game
is off of bootlegs and play action
it would be really weird if baker
mayfield hadn't played pretty well last
year right like
you're not going to get a better
situation than baker mayfield had last
year and has this year which by the way
is what makes the contract situation for
him kind of interesting right like do
you pay him over 40 million dollars when
i would venture to guess there's at
least 20 guys in the nfl that could
perform as well as baker did last year
under the same circumstances
yeah it's tricky i don't want to pay him
uh too too soon okay again i might have
to pay him a little bit more but i want
to see what this season's all about can
you imagine your former coach bill
belichick
having a starting quarterback
mac jones start the season opener
i can
yeah
you know the fact that he put brady in
that second year after bledsoe got hurt
and then never put bledsoe back in
i i think belichick just goes with who
he thinks the better guy is and that was
proof of it you know brady didn't really
play that great
while bledsoe was hurt they just won a
bunch of games and they thought
we think he's playing a little better
than drew but it wasn't like he was tom
brady back then
i think if belichick believes mac jones
is one-tenth of one percent
better than cam newton that he'll start
mac jones
uh i don't think that's gonna happen i
think he'll start cam newton in the
opener but honestly dan if cam newton
has a bad first half
in the opener i wouldn't be surprised if
mac jones goes in there
it feels like the offense is built
more for mac jones
because bill and josh mcdaniels are
accustomed to that style of quarterback
that guy who has the same
characteristics here cam is just a
rental the question is how long are you
renting him for because nobody else was
interested in cam newton until bill
brought him in
you got running backs you got a good
offensive line the defense will probably
be formidable
skill position you brought in some you
know new tight ends but i don't i don't
know if it's a great offense here that's
why i still keep leaning towards cam i
think cam gives them a dimension that
they need this year where maybe they
won't need that next year because they
will go out and get a couple of wide
receivers to help out mac jones what do
you think of that philosophy uh totally
agree you know i i've you know the
patriots played the eagles last week so
i was talking with some people for the
patriots then they're going to run the
crap out of the ball yeah i mean their
rookie running back randray stevenson
from oklahoma he is a stud their
offensive line is legit and i think
quite frankly now that they have mac
jones as a number two and even brian
hoyer as a three
i think they're gonna run cam newton a
lot yeah i think they think that's their
way to win games is to run the heck out
of the ball and i think they'd rather do
that and have that element with cam
early
and see how that goes great to talk to
you as always we'll talk to you during
the season have fun tonight thank you
buddy
my pleasure dan i wanted to say
congratulations on the hall of fame to
be honest i kind of thought you were
already in it but uh congratulations
it's awesome thank you ross you're right
it was an oversight by the hall of fame
it
took a little longer than it should but
uh thank you i appreciate that all right
take care that's ross tucker former nfl
lineman host of the ross tucker football
podcast he'll be on the call for the
eagles at the jets 7 30 eastern on the
eagles television network